أصيب ستة أشخاص في
هجوم طعن في محطة قطار غادونود الرئيسية في باريس ،
ويقول المسؤولون
إن أحدهم في حالة حرجة
تعيش ميليسا بيل في باريس هذا الصباح بالنسبة لنا
ميليسا.
لقد سمعنا كريستين
أنها قالت إنها كانت على مدار الساعة السادسة والأربعين من عمرها ، لذا فإن ساعة الذروة
بدأت للتو عندما ذهب هذا الرجل
في رحلة الهيجان وليس بسكين
يقولونه ولكن نوعًا من أنواع
الشفرات في المنزل لا نعرف المزيد من
التفاصيل حول  السلاح الذي تم استخدامه
وما هو غير عادي للغاية كريستين هو
أن الهجوم حدث في غضون دقيقة واحدة في
تلك الدقيقة الفردية ، حيث
نجح في إصابة ستة أشخاص كما تقول
أحدهم بشكل خطير ثم
تم إنزاله من قبل ضباط الشرطة خارج الخدمة
الذين تمكنوا  لإطلاق النار عليه أطلقوا النار ثلاث
مرات ، نحن نتفهم أنه في
حالة حرجة بين الحياة والموت ، ولكن
حتى تتمكن الشرطة من التحدث معه
ومعرفة المزيد عن دوافعه ،
لم يكن هناك مكافحة للإرهاب
بدأ التحقيق هنا في باريس ، لذلك
في الوقت الحالي لا نعرف شيئًا عن
دوافعه ، كل ما نعرفه هو مشهد
ذلك الهيجان لمدة دقيقة واحدة
والجنون الذي لا بد أنه تم
تنفيذه به بوضوح شديد
المشاهد هنا في ما هو واحد من
أكثر محطات القطارات ازدحامًا في أوروبا ،
توقفت كريستين في دقيقة واحدة من الهجوم حتى عندما كانت المحطة الحجرية تملأ الأشخاص الذين يصطفون بالداخل الآن بشكل أساسي إلى لندن وإلى وجهات أخرى في
شمال أوروبا ، لكن
مشاهد مروعة للغاية هنا
لأي شخص كان في هذا القطار
في دقيقة واحدة فقط
تمكن خلالها من الذهاب إلى الهيجان بهذه
السكين